David, who is responsible for the destruction
of the Republican Party?
The first question is, has the Republican
Party been destroyed?
It's not clear.
Most Trump, most Republican voters still support
Trump.
So it remains to be seen.
However, yes, Trump lost the White House in
twenty eighteen.
Trump's nonsense lost the House for Republicans
in 2020.
Trump's nonsense lost the Senate for Republicans.
So that's true.
But I don't think the vast majority of the
blame should go to Trump.
It's the voters who put Trump in who were
radicalized by the right wing media whose
influence grows and grows and grows.
And it was abetted by the Republican officials
who stood by and mostly let let Trump do his
thing.
So, yes, Trump's actions were bad and Trump's
actions are responsible for him losing in
2020.
And Trump lost them the house in twenty eighteen
in the Senate in 2020.
But the real responsibility lies with those
who allowed Trump to get in in the first place
due to voters who voted for him and Republican
elected officials who stood aside and right
wing media that cheerlead the entire thing.
And in a way, you can sort of say that this
started with the radicalization under Ronald
Reagan in the early 1980s.
It was accelerated by Newt Gingrich in the
mid 90s, who Newt Gingrich really brought
in this style of politics that was owned.
The Libs.
I mean, now that's what it's called.
They didn't call it that in the mid 90s, but
Newt Gingrich's idea was just obstruct Democrats
for the sake of obstruction, opposed Democrats
on everything for the sake of opposition.
And that's how we went from Nixon, who created
the EPA to Jim Inhofe in the Senate holding
a snowball, claiming it to be evidence that
global warming and climate change aren't something
we need to worry about.
So there are feedback loops here, and it can
be hard to say exactly where it started and
what's responsible.
Trump is hugely guilty for damaging the Republican
Party, but Trump doesn't get to be president
or even Republican nominee where he not enabled
by Republican voters and right wing media.
And those are the very same Republicans who
now are partially radicalized because Donald
Trump's way of thinking about politics was
a signal boosted by right wing media over
the last four years.
So when I really think about blame in terms
of the future of the Republican Party, which
is still a question mark, Trump was and has
been exactly who we believed that he was.
Now, a lot of right wing voters didn't believe
it, but we knew who Trump was.
He doesn't care about anybody but himself.
He ignored what is his real job and instead
lobbed attacks at enemies, didn't do the things
he had to do, mishandled every major challenge.
And then when he lost eventually, which was
the right outcome based on his actions, he
blamed everybody else for that as well.
And when we say who who is ultimately really
responsible, it is Trump, but it's right wing
media and it's Republican elected officials
who could have stopped this a long time ago.
And it's Republican voters as well.
And that leads us to what is a rebuilt Republican
Party look like.
I don't know how the Republican Party comes
together to rebuild to the extent that they're
now out of power in the House, Senate and
White House.
How do they rebuild without dealing with the
Q and on a Newsmax Trumpy wing?
I don't know the answer to that, but we have
time to look at that.
It is the beginning of the Biden era.
Come Monday, I will have a report for you
about has Joe Biden gotten done the things
he said were week one and day one priorities.
This is a different phase, but we will see
what the future of the Republican Party is.
Stay with us for the bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom.